[Musique]
dans la cuisine italienne c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'élise et ça fera marche qui
rassemble beaucoup au fromage à la crème
qu'on connaît très bien sous canada le
mascarpone ce fromage italien crémeux et
bien plus qu'une simple garniture pour
préparer le fameux tirer buisson
le mascarpone que vous vendez ici c'est
de l'importation oui on a la marque
albanie c'est une démarche plus fameux
de fromages italiens et après on a la
martinique garda une des plus grands
producteurs de mascarpone en italie
des masques harper on les retrouve dans
des plats principal de beaucoup des
pattes et au sida le dr francesco et
chef dans cette épicerie fine du
centre-ville de montréal
j'ai des souvenirs quand j'étais petite
ma grand mère il faisait des mois à la
maison la ferme on faisait pas mal de
mascarpone ensemble et c'était les
goûter un peu d enfance avait pas eu une
enfance triste
et mascara qui donne une autre italie on
retrouve des témoignages les 1600 déjà
et sans viande allemand masse capella
qui est de dire ricotta dans galette du
nord en fait c'est les mêmes conditions
que la récolte mais c'est fait avec de
la crème la gigantesque vague avec du
lait de vache
les masques hartl c'est très facile à
faire première chose qu'on a besoin
c'est de la crème que c'est la base vous
avez pris une crème 35 c'est un crime
normal 35% ou et j'ai emmené ma crème à
90 degrés là on a juste note jus de
citron avec l'aide d'un fouet on va de
biens ménagers et on peut voir déjà
qu'il a consisté à de la crème qui
change et qui commence à figer dans peu
plus une fois versé dans un poteau
fromage la préparation doit reposer au
moins 24 heures au frigo
voilà c'est ça c'est le masque approche
unique lg fayer on peut les lacets même
48 heures les plus de temps mais là
c'est cool et on allait se reposer les
plus durs et compact ça va devenir comme
on peut voir ici on a laissé un groupe i
la partie mais guaino qui restent qui a
rendu les mascarpone aussi combat c'est
fini c'est fini voilà ça à peu près en
40 et 50 % de gras alors c'est quand
même assez riche comme ingrédients mais
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'utiliser une tonne pour entonner le
goût donné la texture qu'on veut
exactement ce patricia au couteau
connaît bien les fromages italiens elle
en importe au quotidien alors les vaches
laboy ils broutent l'herbe et zale ça
donne un goût vraiment particulier au
mascarpone m
c'est le mascarpone et brach à lattes
qui vient de la région de la lombardie
en fait le mascarpone et italiens est
fabriquée avec du lait la crème
c'est le cas de ceux mascarpone importé
d'italie par c'est plutôt plusieurs
mascarpone et qui sont fabriqués ici au
canada ils ont les mêmes ingrédients
comme base mais ils sont désagrégées
additionnel qui sont ajoutés pour
rallonger la conservation ça contribue
aussi à la différence de goût ces
produits d'épicerie se conservent
jusqu'à 90 jours au frigo mais une fois
ouvert vous avez une semaine pour les
consommer
ça fait des boucles mascarpone merci
notre chef nous présente d'abord le
mascarpone on tartine tomates cerises
loi des globes et horrifiée et fines
herbes des provinces mais moi je trouve
que ça c'est d'une grande simplicité
mais c'est sûr que ça va être bon c'est
pour toutes les occasions ça peut faire
une petite entrée ça peut faire un petit
goûter l'après midi haussiers même un
prix petit déjeuner ça peut être fun je
pense avec les doigts ce qu'il fallait
prendre ça
on peut y aller fort avec les doigts
c'est tellement bon de mascarpone avec
la petite touche du village juste ça
vraiment beau jean dollé le poivre avec
un petit zeste de citron de dans
l'électrique a dit noah se pose problème
avec ça c'est vraiment très très belle
idée
on va présenter décalé launay à la
courge musquée mais salariale de la
sauce et du mascarpone avec du parmesan
et de la sauce tomate c'est l'fun
d'avoir quelque chose de creuseurs jagla
j'aurais dit si c'était pas du masque
après j'aurais utilisé de la ricotta
mais vu que les masques a passé un peu
les rois des fromages mal à l'italie je
me suis dit que ça pourrait être mon
idée de remplacer savoir tap
le crème et le bonbon
c'est un goût c'est un nombre sans
hésiter il avait dit un peu plus tôt le
la douceur
mascarte lacie d2 jamaat avec l'ema
certains commencent à julien parce que
sa coupe après l'intensité de la de
mascarpone puis le sucre et des courants
jouent vraiment un très bel équilibre
en échec
et pour changer du tiramisu notre chef à
préparer un dessert type et d'italie un
bien commun djiar et mascarpone avec une
petite génoise à l' orange et compagne
de canneberges sans dire un dessert de
noël ou à l'expiration c'est un peu noël
avec les canneberges
je trouve que les basilic avec les
canneberges c'est vraiment le fun vont
passer un beau temps n'est pas parti
[Musique]